live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the Dave Ramsey
show where debt is dumb cash is king and
the paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the BMW as the status symbol of
choice
now you hardcore Dave Ramsey listeners
just noticed a change some of you had
drove past you and you didn't notice it
some of you were like what just happened
well occasionally in business
occasionally in radio something special
occurs and this is a very special thing
that has happened it began in March of
last year it began years before that
because I as a debit card user I've been
pissed off at rental car companies for
decades because they treat us like
second-class citizens and forever I have
thought if a debt if a rental car
company would finally get it get the
memo that those of us that have a debit
cards are by and large better risks than
those of you that are deeply in debt
with a credit card when we rent your
dadgum car so I took this call last
March let's play it well different car
companies are they move around so much
on their policies we can't keep up with
them we've actually been trying to get
one or two of them to just say we'll
just take a debit card because then we
could advertise form tell fifteen
million people that you could go to a
certain brand that'd be valuable to them
but none of them that out yet so I don't
know today who takes them and who
doesn't there's always somebody that
does and there's always somebody that
doesn't I got tired of chasing them
begging them to offer debit cards and do
the right thing one of you are listening
that there's an executive of the
rent-a-car company here's a hint
I'll tell 15 million people to use your
service if you will accept a debit card
and quit penalizing people who actually
have a brain and got rid of that all
their credit cards and use a debit card
people like me well that was fairly
plain fairly easy to understand so a guy
named James is driving along listening
to the radio he lives in Fort Myers
Florida he happens to be married
to Susan Jacobs who is the senior vice
president of brands for dollar car
rental she is in a meeting while I'm
saying that with some of her senior
executives in the Hertz corporation
which owns dollar car rental and her
husband is frantically texting her and
sending her the clip of the audio in the
text saying you think ya think yeah yeah
thank you guys I don't look at this and
because he's a big Dave fan of course
and so the weird thing was we ended up
connecting with dollar and because of
that and Susan Jacobs the senior vice
president of brands mérida James came
here and with her team and we sat down
and we've had several sit-down
conversations with them here in our
offices since March and they heard us
loud and clear that you guys that carry
debit cards don't need to be treated
like second-class citizens when wanting
to rent a car and dollar car rental is a
not only a wonderful company but they've
got some very creative team members and
executives and leadership team and they
do it there's just nice people we got to
know the you know some of the senior
people the chief marketing officers and
so forth in this process and all we were
asking them to do was to say hey take a
debit card and don't mistreat us which
they immediately went you know we get
the memo but we want to go further than
that we want to do all kinds of stuff
for Dave Ramsey listeners and we want to
sponsor like some of your stuff how can
we do that we said well we're sold out
but we'll let you sponsor the studio so
we ended up doing that and so I'm now
sitting in the dollar car rental studio
twenty-eight years I've been doing radio
and we've never sold a sponsorship for
the studio and now we have a sponsorship
for the studio but that's a sidebar
thing oh and there's other stuff that's
coming later but for today we're ready
to announce that dollar car rental loves
you you gave people they love you they
want to treat you like first-class
citizens if you use a debit card for
your car rental if you rent a car from
dollar car rental all you need is a
debit card a driver's license to be 20
years old now you gotta have 200 ollars
in the bank because there's always a
hold put on a debit card just like when
you check into a hotel same there
some kind thing that's a normal deal but
to hold the cost of your rental car and
they don't do a credit check that they
don't hold one of your children in the
vault that they don't point a gun at
your face and question you as if you are
a spy from another planet you simply
walk up with a debit card a driver's
license you're 20 years old you have 200
ollars in the bank you touch down like a
regular person
Wow it's amazing I love this and it was
it was a pretty incredible thing this
the way this all came together off of
that little mini rant I did which I've
done extended rents on debit cards with
credit card with all kinds of
mistreatment that we debit card users
get but the credit the rental car
companies were the worst right not
anymore
don't get to a city and wonder if your
debit card will work because you didn't
do business with dollar
I am so wholeheartedly endorsing this
company why because they completely
changed all of their policies in the
last six months in order for me to do
this today I mean they molded this
program for you people that are
listening and they're following the
stuff we teach and don't have a credit
card this is pretty cool no credit check
you just have a debit card you walk up
with your driver's license and you're 20
years old and you have two dollars in
your account that's it's amazing now
make sure you weren't you're doing this
that you tell them where you heard about
it they're Dave Ramsey fan and this is
the reason I was going to do business
with one of those other brands that I'm
not going to mention it but now because
you're going to treat a debit card at
user like a first-class citizen we're
gonna do business with you here's a
better part of this though even be gets
better it's it's hard to believe it gets
better but gets better if you sign up
for the dollar Express rewards with your
debit card you skip the counter and you
go directly to the dollar lot log on to
dollar dot-com slash Ramsey dollar
dot-com slice Ramsey join the dollar
Express rewards
even if you're not going to travel today
go ahead and get this all set up and it
puts you one step ahead it lets them
know you're a Ramsay fan because you
joined dollar Express rewards at dollar
calm slash Ramsay you walk past the
counter into the parking lot for the car
this is amazing I mean you got this kind
of service with credit cards with some
of the other people but those of us that
have had debit cards I haven't had a
credit card in thirty years and I I'm 30
years worth of pissed off of being
mistreated and some 30 years worth of
celebrating right now that this is
awesomeness not only is it awesomeness
because I actually found a company that
has a leadership team that cares so much
as a huge company that they pivoted
their entire operation where you can
walk in and take your debit card in
there today that was a big deal they got
the memo from you folks that you wanted
this and from me I spoke for you so
don't let me down go to dollar Express
go to dollar dot-com slash ramsey and
sign up for the dollar Express rewards
but anytime you're doing business with
dollar tough dollar car rental you're
kind of you're gonna love the experience
these are great people but be sure and
say I did this because of you people
listening to what Dave was saying on the
radio and changing this is this is good
corporate culture right here this is
actually when business works right when
things when they listen the customer and
change stuff this is amazing I love it I
am now broadcasting from the dollar car
rental studios and proud of it baby this
is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]